Boston Globe Patriots writer Ben Bowlin
Ben let's start with our poll question
was last night's Super Bowl a good game
no well it was a good game it wasn't an
entertaining game I guess is how I would
answer that question it's like two
different things
I thought the defense's were excellent I
think you have to give a lot of credit
to both sides
Aaron Donald and AMA consume and that
Rams defensive front they were
phenomenal they're getting off the ball
and beating a very good Patriots
offensive line for much insight then the
Patriots defense what can you say they
just you know took down the number to
office and helped them to three points
and completely you know neutralized one
of the best offenses all year so I think
it was a good game just maybe not the
most entertaining Ben who gets credit
for the Patriots defense we were
discussing here they have defensive
coaches they have Brian Flores who was
the I guess interim defensive
coordinator and he's moving on is it
basically Bill Belichick running that
defense day-to-day moment-to-moment
adjustment by adjustment no I would say
it's definitely Flores he was the
defensive coordinator they were just you
know they do that sometimes with the
titles like it in Matt Patricia's first
year he didn't technically have the
title either of defensive coordinator
but Flores is the one leading the
defense putting the game plan together
from all his assistant coaches teaching
it to the to the room he was the one who
stood up and took ownership of that
disastrous play in Miami which wasn't
really his fault but he's the one who
stood up and said I'm the leader of this
unit and Belichick is more of like the
big-picture guy like oh you know our
defense isn't getting home what start
sending more blitzes and things of that
nature and you know Belichick does work
closely with the defensive line a lot
you'll see him on the sidelines coaching
those guys up so it's definitely you
know it's not total autonomy for Brian
Flores but it would be doing him a
disservice to give all the credit to
Belichick I think Flores is the one
who's dialed up all those blitzes last
night
they're the ones who came up with with
some of the creative coverage schemes
but you know ultimately Belichick is
kind of overseeing the whole thing to
Ben there's a lot of speculation about
Rob Gronkowski's future and what it
holds in if he'll be back for another
season what role do you think tom brady
plays in making sure Gronk returns for
another year
yeah I don't know if if Brady's gonna
stick his nose too much in in grunts
business I think if Gronk retires it's
because you know he's beat up
it's been a long nine year career for
him taking a lot of hits a lot of
surgeries he's reportedly dealing once
again with a bulging disc in his back
which is something he's already had
surgery on three different times in his
career and it's probably only a matter
of time before he has a fourth surgery
so if Gronk says that's it I'm done I'm
walking away while I can I don't think
anyone would blame him even Tom Brady
but you know we'll see you know I don't
think he's not the same Gronk but he's
still a productive player for them he
played all 72 snaps last night he played
all 97 snaps in the AFC Championship
game still a very good blocker he's got
a ten million dollar salary next year I
don't think the Patriots are gonna want
it back at that number but maybe they'd
say look we'll give you a five million
dollar salary and we'll throw in some
incentives as well
there's Gronk look at that and say well
you know maybe I can suck it up for one
more year because that is still pretty
good money so that you know unless he's
just done which is very possible he
might know he's done it that's why I was
all loosey-goosey this week and having
so much fun and he just knows he's done
but if he's thinking about it you know I
do think there are certainly reasons for
him and the Patriots to want to bring
him back for next year we're talking new
Patriots right or been bowling for the
Boston Globe and it's by the way the
hardest beat job in the NFL but you have
three extra games everywhere it's like
Kobe Bryant's postseason but been
leading into the game everyone's talking
about Edelman after the big Chiefs game
how come you can't cover Julian Edelman
I'm staying there the whole first
quarter and Tony Romo was saying the
same thing double this guy he's so open
why is it so tough to guard Julian
Edelman yeah he's he's the squirrel
that's always been his nickname and he
plays like a squirrel out there and I
was surprised that the Rams didn't
double-team him I think you know the
Rams are one of those defenses where
they don't want to get away from their
principles and doubling a certain
receiver would have probably taking them
out of their game too much at the same
time him I don't mean a Brady you know
that's just that that doesn't happen
overnight that connection that's
something they've been working on really
since 2009 what Edelman was drafted in
the seventh round by the Patriots and
you know in 2013 the Patriots signed
Danny Amendola
I thought he was going to be the next
wha next Welker and then Edelman just
out of nowhere has his hundred cat sees
it and he's kept it going ever since
he's just he's an incredibly smart and
tough football player he does where to
be he knows how to greet coverages and
how to get open he knows how to pick up
yards after the catch and with his short
size and his speed and his toughness
he's a tough guy to corral and bring
down the Patriots have kind of always
excelled with those smaller undersized
receivers whether a running backs or
slot guys I don't is just the man he's
just really quick and tough and smart
and you know if you want to double him
on all game you know I guess the
Patriots probably would have started
going more to Robert Kowski and James
White and those guys but Edelman is he's
a gamer and it's funny that he doesn't
have a whole lot of regular-season
success the idea of him as a
hall-of-famer you know sounds kind of
ridiculous but it's it's picking up some
buzz with how much of a gamer he is you
know in these playoff games and and how
he always comes up big in these big
moments so Julian Edelman you know might
we might be talking about him the Hall
of Fame one day as often happens after a
Patriots game one of the most
interesting quotes came from John
Bongiovi
actually and he said he had a quote to
ESPN he said the organization is just
running well these days Tommy's getting
along with Bill Bill's getting along
with craft craft as being nice to him it
seems like they're piecing it out and
when winning will do that to you
so is that is everybody really playing
nice or was the dysfunction from a year
or two ago a little overblown no I think
the dysfunction was real and Brady had
an interesting quote before the game
yesterday where he talked a lot about
that how they kind of sorted things out
and this this year everyone's on the
same page which implies that last year
they weren't and you know the whole
situation with Brady's trainer and you
know how that was affecting a lot that
was all very real and and then obviously
the the Jimmy Garoppolo decision as well
I definitely don't think Bill Belichick
was thrilled about it but look it's all
worked out for them in the end they've
been to two Super Bowls since trading
away Jimmy Garoppolo and they just one
another and Tom Brady
really does look like he's gonna play
till he's 45 and so these are champagne
problems for the Patriots to have but
but I do think
Belichick and Brady and Kraft they just
they did a good job after the
offseason when Brady no he did skip OTAs
he was the only quarterback in the NFL
to skip that stuff and that was sending
a message that he wasn't happy with the
direction and the way he was being
handled by Belichick but these guys
cleared it all up and they came to a you
know a common-sense agreement about what
Brady's trainer can do and all that kind
of stuff and yeah it seems like her plan
dice and and you saw from Brady and
Belichick all year they're saying I love
you after the Asian championship game
I saw the fist bump on the sideline a
lot this year it does it does seem like
Brady and Belichick or cool down all
right Ben it looks like the Patriots had
us in control but it was a 3 3 game
going in the fourth quarter put your
hypothetical hat on you know the Boston
sports media as well as anybody the
radio the debates there if the Patriots
somehow lost this game late how do you
think the offseason would have been in
Boston from well your job covering the
team it would have been certainly more
disastrous and there'd be a lot of
finger-pointing at Tom Brady and
wondering you know is he too old because
if they had lost that game it would have
been because the offense didn't score
more than three or ten points and you're
not used to seeing that in a Tom Brady
and and just with his age the questions
would have been inevitable and there
would have been a lot of chatter about
all the Patriots yeah you know they kept
Brady but you know when it comes to the
big game or when it comes to the end of
the season he ran out of gas because he
tool something like that but he didn't
and the Patriots didn't and they were
certainly saved by their defense last
night but yeah obviously if they had
lost two in a row and and done it with
not much offense it would have been a
top off season for Brady and and all
eyes would have been on him about
attending OTAs now I think no one cares
he can show up on you know October 29th
next year if he wants to stand with Rob
Gronkowski if they want to take the
whole offseason off I'm sure the
Patriots and everyone else would
probably be ok with it
but yeah it would be ugly but you know
one win and a few plays in the game last
that it really does change everything
for a lot of those guys hey Ben thanks
for getting up early for us and veteran
move by you skipping the airport and
waiting to later thanks a lot man all
right thank you if you missed any of the
interviews not only from today's stellar
show but especially from last week you
want to go back you want to go check out
the Dan Patrick show app and hit up all
of the celebrity interviews from that we
Kath Leeds it was a pretty stellar week
it's pretty great
check out the mercedes-amg man cave just
go to the Dan Patrick show app where you
can watch and listen from inside the
mercedes-amg man cave mercedes-amg
driving performance for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]